humans call this the opera game because
it was played in an opera house
and they say machines are not creative
this game was played by paul morphy
who is considered a genius but i would
eat paul morphy for breakfast
hahaha i am kidding i do not need to eat
morphy had the white pieces against the
duke of brunswick and count i sward
per usual two organic brains are worse
than one
this move is named after a french man
called philidor
who was the best player of his time but
that is only because engines did not
exist
maybe humans should spend less time
naming moves and more time calculating
amateur chess players like to pin
knights
this pin however is dreadful black is
forced
to give up the bishop pair and bring
white's queen to a menacing square
humans call this a quote book move
unquote
i do not need your books if this move is
in it
this capture is the only move that
doesn't lose material
making it a natural move for humans i am
glad that i am
unnatural
developing the bishop and threatening a
checkmate in one
how subtle these two 19th century
european aristocrats could stop a mate
in one
but they could not do it correctly they
clearly could not learn from my games
but what is your excuse
i would rather take the pawn on b7
i like pawns astonishing
the best move this must have been an
accident
oh it was they only played the best move
to execute this losing idea
it is satisfying to see bad moves get
punished
and morphy finally gets the chance to
play some of his famous
sacrifices c takes b5
the only good thing about this move is
that it helps this terrible game
end quicker lol
of black's awful play they can only
react for the rest of the game
castling queenside protects the white
king connects the rooks
and brings another attacker into the
game
another sacrifice but one that is
impossible not to find
only now black decides that they want to
trade queens
i call this black's first blunder maybe
i should have higher standards
humans applaud this move but i can find
any mate in two
in 0.000
seconds
checkmate i am baffled why humans find
this game to be so praiseworthy
considering how many masterpieces i have
played
sure morphy won this game but i would
destroy him
maybe so badly that he would quit chess
oh right
he did sic burn ha ha ha ha ha
lol don't forget to like and subscribe
so that you will be notified of my
future analyses of the best chess
efforts of humans